OPENING FOR A 2024 GOP
ALTERNATIVE TO DONALD TRUMP?
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> SAY WHAT YOU WANT ABOUT CHRIS
CHRISTIE, AT LEAST HE DOESN'T
RETREAT WHEN ASKED IF HE WOULD
RUN AGAINST TRUMP IN 2024.
>> WOULD YOU RUN IF TRUMP RUNS?
>> SURE.
>> SO YOU'LL RUN AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP?
>> SURE.
>> WHERE IS THE CAMERA?
PUT THIS CAMERA ON CHRIS
CHRISTIE'S FACE.
YOU'LL RUN AGAINST DONALD TRUMP?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY OTHER GOP
POTENTIAL CANDIDATE FALLS LOOK A
LAWN CHAIR WHEN THEY GET THAT
QUESTION.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEIR LOYALTY
WILL BENEFIT THEM IF TRUMP
DECIDES NOT TO RUN.
THAT'S BANANAS.
THEY SHOULD KNOW TRUMP IS ONLY
LOYAL TO HIMSELF.
CHRISTIE IS APPLYING EXPERIENCE
TO THE PROBLEM.
HE'S PROBABLY KNOWN BACKING
DONALD WAS A BAD IDEA SINCE HIS
BODY LANGUAGE AT THE RAMBLING
PRESS CONFERENCE.
DESPITE SUPPORTING TRUMP FOR
MOST OF THE ADMINISTRATION,
CHRISTIE DID SPEAK UP ON JANUARY
6th AND HASN'T STOPPED.
BUT MUCH OF THE REST OF THE GOP
IS SUFFERING FROM STOCKHOLM
SYNDROME.
THEY THINK THEIR CAPTOR IS THEIR
SAVIOR.
HE'S NOT.
BY ANY OBJECTIVE MEASURE DONALD
TRUMP IS A DRAG ON THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
NOT STRONG.
HE'S SELF-EVIDENTLY WEAK.
TWO-TIME POPULAR VOTE LOSER, IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE DELUSIONAL
SEDITIONIST.
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS ARE AFRAID
OF HIS BASE, THEY EITHER CAN'T
SEE IT OR WON'T ADMIT IT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT WIN BY GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE SEEN WITH
THE GUY.
AND HE OUTPERFORMED DONALD TRUMP
IN EVERY SINGLE COUNTY IN
VIRGINIA.
WON OVER SUBURBAN AND SWING
VOTERS WHO VIEWED TRUMP AS
TOXIC.
YES, TRUMP IS DELIRIOUSLY
POPULAR WITH THE BASE.
BUT THERE IS ALREADY EVIDENCE OF
A CLEAR LANE FOR A GOP CANDIDATE
NOT NAMED DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
SEPTEMBER POLL FROM CNN.
WHEN ASKED WHETHER REPUBLICANS
HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF WINNING
IN 2024 WITH TRUMP OR SOMEONE
ELSE, 49% SAID SOMEONE ELSE.
BASICALLY HALF THE GOP, JUST
WAITING FOR A COMPELLING
ALTERNATIVE.
BRAND-NEW DES MOINES REGISTER
POLL MAKES THE SAME POINT IN
STARKER TURNS, 61% OF IOWA
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY'RE MORE IN
LINE WITH THE GOP COMPARED TO
THE 26% WHO SAY THEIR PRIMARY
LOYALTY IS TO TRUMP.
THERE IS A CLEAR OPENING HERE,
PEOPLE.
AND TRUMP'S WEAKNESS IS A
GENERAL ELECTION CANDIDATE IS
ALREADY EVIDENT.
REMEMBER, HE'S MASSIVELY
UNPOPULAR WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AS A WHOLE.
HE LEFT OFFICE WITH A 34%
APPROVAL RATING, HE'S THE ONLY
PRESIDENT IN THE HISTORY OF
GALLUP TO NEVER HIT 50%.
IN OCTOBER, THE COLLEGE POLL
FOUND THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD A
37% APPROVAL RATE.
YOU IMAGINE THAT A CREDIBLE GOP
CANDIDATE WOULD EASILY BEAT
BIDEN IN A HYPOTHETICAL MATCHUP,
RIGHT?
BUT THAT POLL FOUND BIDEN AND
TRUMP TIED AT 40%, WITH 14%
SAYING THEY WOULD VOTE FOR
SOMEONE ELSE.
THAT'S A POLITICAL EQUIVALENT OF
LOSING MONEY WHILE OWNING THE
CASINO.
FEAR IS WHAT IS KEEPING
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS FROM SEEING
THIS CLEARLY.
AND THAT COWARDICE SHOULD BE
ALMOST AS DISQUALIFYING FOR A
POTENTIAL COMMANDER IN CHIEF AS
TRYING TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION
BASED ON A LIE.
THERE ARE HONORABLE EXCEPTIONS,
LIZ CHENEY, ADAM KINZINGER,
ANTHONY GONZALEZ, WHO SPOKE OUT
CLEARLY AND CONSISTENTLY ABOUT
THE CULT OF PERSONALITY THAT HAS
TAKEN OVER THE GOP, AND ITS
DANGEROUS IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THEY HAVE GOT EXCOMMUNICATED FOR
THEIR HONESTY.
LIZ CHENEY, THE CONSERVATIVE
DAUGHTER OF THE FORMER VP,
OFFICIALLY KICKED OUT OF HER
HOME STATE GOP.
BUT WHAT IF SHE AND OTHER RED
STATE NEVER TRUMPERS RAN AS
INDEPENDENTS IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION?
THERE IS EVERY REASON TO THINK
THEIR NAME I.D. AND PRINCIPLED
INDEPENDENCE WOULD BE REWARDED
OUTSIDE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES.
AFTER ALL, THAT'S WHAT ALASKA
SENATOR LISA MURKOWSKI DID WHEN
SHE LOST A PRIMARY TO A TEA
PARTY HARD-LINER IN 2010 AND SHE
WON AS A WRITE-IN CANDIDATE.
THAT'S ONE WAY TO BREAK THE
STOCKHOLM SYNDROME THAT CAPTURED
THE GOP.
IT IS SELF-EVIDENTLY INSANE TO
TREAT A FAILED EX-PRESIDENT WHO
TRIED TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION AS
THE INEVITABLE NEXT NOMINEE.
NOTHING IS INEVITABLE.
AND IF CONSERVATIVE MEANS
ANYTHING, IT MEANS TRYING TO
CONSERVE OUR BASIC SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT.
SO WE NEED CANDIDATES WITH THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP AND TELL THE
TRUTH.
TRUMP IS WEAK.
AMERICA IS STRONG.
AND THAT'S YOUR REALITY CHECK.
>> WHAT'S TELLING IS IF AND WHEN
ANOTHER NATIONALLY PROMINENT
REPUBLICAN IN ADDITION TO CHRIS
CHRISTIE STANDS UP AND SAYS A